we had no such difficulty getting a few
words out of Damien McBride today he is
here in Brighton although he hasn't
actually been given a pass which would
allow him into the conference so I met
up with him this morning and began by
asking how much money he'd made from the
book I've done well out of writing in
this book and you know I make no gray
apologies for that so I mean that's this
the amount that was paid for it I've
also given the royalties from actual
sales of the book to charity partly so
that you know people buying it there
might not want to put any money to my
office at least so now that's going to a
good cause but the theorization people
are talking about six-figure so yeah I
think you know I've seen that reported
and you know it is around that level so
off the publishers have their share in
taxman have their share I'll be quite
well out of it these confessions of
yours I'm you know I you're a Roman
Catholic I believe I mean I do believe
you did wrong yeah I mean did seriously
wrong and affected many people's lives
in a hugely damaging way and and you
know lots of those people were
politicians who know the kind of rough
and tumble of politics some of them were
you know quite bruises themselves but
lots of them were totally innocent civil
servants and one of the things that's
been particularly painful this week is
reading some of the reactions from
people who were you know ordinary civil
servants or advisors to those ministers
you know reacting with a bit of horror
frankly about what what they've read I
mean you know I've been in this world
for a long time as you have I mean what
surprised me was you admit that so much
of what you did was friendly far I mean
doing in people on your own side yeah
and part of that I mean you know how
could have I could have said lots and I
do have lots in the book about the
operations against the conservative
party both legitimate ones and and that
was what was exceptional that it wasn't
about furthering the Labour cause it was
about furthering Gordon Brown yeah I
think I think so much that reflects the
period that we went through you know
which I was only parts you know in later
years from 1997 where because the loge
party was so dominant in government
because it's a dirty party wasn't really
getting a look in then it almost became
this sort of you know internal struggle
was the only debate in politics and and
that was a serious struggle at times a
serious debate about the policy
direction of of the Labour Party it was
really about Gordon Brown wanting the
top job wasn't it oh it was about Paul
Brown you know over over the years
having control over vast areas of
government and ultimately about him
succeeding Tony Blair I mean anybody
basically who's a threat to his
ambitions you went out and tried to
squash John Reed Shree Blair
Charles Clark I mean he but as I'm
saying the difference is I felt that
those people were not only rivals to
call Dan Brown or any threats to Gordon
Brown's succession but were actively
engaged in trying to undermine him and
you know trying to take him on I mean
someone like Charles Clark was a sort of
you know very very active critic of
Gordon Brown a very damaging critic but
really I mean we you know as you go into
the but when you had to resign it was
about thinking about disseminating lies
about prominent conservatives wasn't it
unsubstantiated stories but that was yes
that sighs there were unsubstantiated
stories I think it's not things you made
very clear in the book that they weren't
things I was made of the things that I
was told by people and sort of you know
bleed at the time obviously they turn
out to be unsubstantiated but that's I
certainly wasn't in the business of
making things up and amidst all the
things that have been said about me
there are very few other than the few
that I've admitted to in the book which
could genuinely be described as sort of
VO either making up lies or or you know
spreading false rumors about people
there even after you resigned in 2009
Gordon Brown stayed in touch with you
not really no no no I mean we didn't
have any verbal contact
at all from the moment I resigned until
after he left office the only thing I
had in that whole time was a voicemail
from him asking if my mom and my
girlfriend were okay let's be clear
about this you felt licensed by him to
do what you did no I didn't I didn't
feel licensed by him I felt that I had a
freedom to operate in the way that I did
and that was entirely because of what
intelligence I was able to bring back to
him and the sort of contacts that I was
able to bring back to him from parts of
the media that's other late politicians
couldn't reach you but you know I've had
conversations with Gordon Brown he was
paranoid about people briefing against
him as he used to put it which suggested
me that he knew that he was quite
capable of briefing against others I
think it was more than when Gordon Brown
would see stories like that he would
always have a very clear idea in his own
mind who had been responsible for them
and so over the years you know he would
hear him say to them
Mandelson all that must be Tessa Robin
so Gordon Brown never said to you
such-and-such a Labour politician is a
threat to me let's see what we can do
about tonight never never absolutely not
never and he didn't know what you were
doing
no it's only the only solace that you'd
ever have any kind discussion about that
was when there was an active coup in in
motion so when they were discussions for
instance around David Miliband in August
2008 when he wrote his article which was
sort of seen as firing the gun of a
potential leadership threat what are
these emails that you think may be
around that Ed Miliband would be well
advised to destroy I don't know I mean I
wasn't just reporting what was said to
me at the time that when I sat down and
Derek Draper and you know and he said
that there might be this problem with
these red rag emails he also said I I
asked him you know who else could have a
problem and and he's a Peter Mandelson
James Pannell ed Miliband now when the
Peter Mandelson emails to Derek trade
became out they would just you know
there was reasonably innocuous they were
just about Gordon having an image
problem that kind of things so they
weren't they weren't sort of anything of
the scale that I was up to so I would
imagine that's what he meant from James
Bond Ellen's and Ed Miliband was just
you know personal contact of stuff that
you know might be a little embarrassing
because it's giving your personal news
what they were spreading rumors them no
no no no I don't think it would've been
anything like that and that's not you
know ed Miliband is not that sort of
person that's not the way your price so
ed Miliband didn't know what you do know
not so well the the point of which Ed
Miliband concluded that you know that I
was a bad thing and I needed be got rid
of was when he assumed wrongly that I
was briefing against him after the
election never was in 2007 and that's
when he sort of turned on me and and as
time went on became one of those people
that were saying to golden brown you
have to remove him from this preparation
where does this leave you now leaves me
having told my story which is something
I wanted to do and you know I'll go on
my life I've got no ambitions to get
back into politics and haven't really
for you know since since I left really
well no and then they say I say in the
book that I don't think I was suited to
that life or certainly became something
that was very corrosive for me over time
and I'm not blaming politics for that
but certainly the longer I was in the
system the worse my behavior became